and from the spirit awards to the acm
awards the biggest names in country
music touched down in vegas and we've
got all the stars before they hit the
stage we're all together we're in vegas
we're in this gorgeous beautiful giant
space
and i feel like everybody is just rising
to the occasion the fact that we're able
to collaborate
in here together is pretty special i
walked in i think this is probably my
favorite acm so far i'm excited it feels
like
really high energy and fun we're so
excited to be back together with our
friends in country music we're opening
the show me and gabby i'm doing an elvis
song i've never sung before in my life
so uh yeah we'll see how that goes and
then i'm doing a
solo song
i hope you dance she sure is gabby
barrett and jimmy allen prep for hosting
duties alongside dolly but as for
wardrobe who has the most number of
wardrobe changes
and normally i would defer to dolly but
i don't know jimmy allen changed clothes
a lot chris young and mitchell 10 penny
are set to perform their smash hit at
the end of a bar and for mitchell this
kind of venue is a first this is my
first time in the stadium as ears i've
never played a stadium ever so yeah
my attempt to backflip i don't know
we'll see i'm gonna be moving a lot
during my performance so that's fun i
get to really interact with the fans for
the very first time the show will not
air on a major network instead it will
be streamed live
on prime video i'm excited
excited to be here and perform and be up
for a few awards so looking forward to
it it's gonna be really cool